programmatic buying allows you to use
audience insights and technology to
tailor messages to the right person at
the right moment in the right context it
was known in the past as real-time
bidding as it helps you respond to
real-time signals across screens and
across channels but today it's much more
than real-time bidding it's everything
related to media buying decisions that
is done by an automated system rather
than manually for example if a dog owner
was booking his travel online and was
interrupted in the middle to take his
dog for a walk programmatic buying can
help us at a bar kman to target this dog
owner on his phone and make sure he is
booking his apartment on his Mart phone
on the go the secret here is to really
define your audience well if you do this
successfully you are more likely to send
them the most relevant message research
has shown that when an ad is delivered
in real time to an individual there are
twice as likely to interact with it